Everything one does in life should be for
the interest of fun.
Not fun merely in the sense of play or leisure,
but fun in the sense of deriving excitement
and enjoyment from life in general.
We must alter our perspective of life in such
a way that prompts a movie-like observational
experience of it.
A second person perspective that enables us
to find entertainment and intrigue in both
the hardships and the joys of life.
It is easy to slip into the feeling that life
is pointless when you neglect the objective
of fun.
When you ignore fun, you become hung up on
destructive mindsets and routines.
You work and worry and adopt the delusion
that fun will come at the end of life.
But it won’t.
Your journey will end sooner than later, and
when it does, you can’t take anything with
you.
And all the fun you’ve been waiting to have
won’t carry over.
We can’t store life away in the closet,
hoping it will accrue in value.
Life is not like a vintage sports memorabilia
hat or jersey.
You cannot wait fifty years without touching
it and then sell it for profit.
It only has any value when you wear and enjoy
it right now.
Life crumbles of all meaning when we become
stuck to this idea that someone will buy our
life at the end of it, just because it is
in mint, untouched condition.
There will be no buyer and we will have forgotten
how to simply have fun and laugh at the obscurity
of it all.
Imagine life as just one day.
Just like an actual day, if you wake up too
late, or not all, you miss out on experiencing
it.
And you want to be awake for it as much as
you can.
Wake up and understand that life is not something
to hide under the covers from.
Realize that life can be serious but does
not have to be arduous.
Take care of the tasks required to function
in the modern world but know that they are
temporary and not to be solely identified
with.
WHAT you do in life is far less relevant than
HOW you do the “what” in life.
There are innumerable belief systems and ways
of living out the “what” in life, but
they are all bound by the same desired life-force
of fun and enjoyment.
You can either give life a point by seeing
it as an incredible opportunity to experience
the reality of the world as your unique consciousness,
embracing your profound ability to play with
life like a malleable clay-like substance.
Or you can live with your arms crossed and
pout in the corner.
Your choice.